this week on couch tomatoes we're
talking HBO's Watchmen and giving you
our fresh picks on what to watch what's
up guys I'm a surprise welcome back to
couch tomato sponsored by for shut a
pizza this is a show where we talk about
the latest TV and why you should tune in
and today on the show we were diving
deep into HBO's Watchmen I am so stoked
because joining me on the couch today is
Shane Maday and Ryan Bergara from
BuzzFeed's unsolved welcome back welcome
back happy to be here dad happy to be
back on the couch I'm excited you guys
are here and the beautiful Roxy striker
from Collider hey guys happy to be here
for the first time you guys have seen
Watchmen yeah yes we have yes oh for
sure Oh first I joke because they are
major fans so I'm so stoked to get into
this with you guys
so let's students set in present day
three decades after the release of the
graphic novel by Alan Moore which takes
place in the 1980s the new series is
already getting a lot of praise from
critics and it's currently a certified
fresh' with 98% on the tomato meter at
the time of this recording
now guys damon lindelof the creator has
been very open about the fact that this
is not a remake but a remix continuation
of the 1986 comic but I know Watchmen is
very polarizing so I need to know what
do people need to know when they tune in
to this show do they need to read the
graphic novel or have seen Zack Snyder's
film that came out in 2009 I know what's
going on well this is much more relevant
to the novel as opposed to the movie we
see things in episode 1 like the squid
falling from the sky that is reminiscent
of the novel and the ending they're not
the movie but I think that you could go
into this blind if you really wanted to
they're telling their own story with new
characters and so it kind of depends on
how deep of a dive you want to do
beforehand but they're really trying to
make it so that if you are a new fan to
Watchmen that you can be a new fan and
still enjoy the series you guys think
the same thing because I thought that at
first but then I was like I don't know
there's things like the Watchmen son is
the name of the play that Jeremy Irons
is character puts on I'm like how would
you know I'm trying to put myself in the
brain of someone who's not familiar with
it I feel like I would be overwhelmed I
feel like people should look at their
calendar figure out how much free time
they have you know if you're busy person
watch the movie you'll sort of get it
without the very good ending of the
squid
if you don't if you have more time read
the novel it's so good and it's very
readable it's not daunting I will say in
today's age though to make someone have
a homework assignment you have to enjoy
this you know a piece of work is a lot I
actually think you can't go into it
blind I think it would help obviously to
have some of the prior materials but I
do think it's very watchable and it says
right and I love that watchable I'm in
if you guys go to HBO comm slash
Watchmen they created this PDP dia and
they have a lot of source material there
to go show so I think that's kind of an
easy way to get into it I don't even
know it but yeah I want to get into the
controversies of making the show but
before I do I'm gonna kick it back to a
combo I had with Roxy about the best way
to prep before a big TV binge check it
out
Roxy are you so excited to be on the
show today yes thank you so much for
having me over to watch some episodes
and just kind of relax relax get relaxed
we have to stay active while we're
watching TV what do you mean active you
know active like standing up to go get
food walking all the way over to the
kitchen stretching to get that bomb food
photo it's all exercise okay that's the
kind of exercise I can actually get
behind okay good because after our
workouts I have a reward for us I made
us it's unreal for shut up brick oven
spinach and mushroom pizza the crust is
so crunchy and amazing and there are all
these mushrooms and spinach on it which
are basically superfood 100% and thank
goodness for pizza because who knew
watching TV was so much work listen it
is a tough job but someone's got to do
it alright guys so when the watchmen
graphic novel came out it was
groundbreaking in many ways mainly
because it was a reflection of our
deepest fears right like the Cold War
was top of mind
nuclear apocalypse was still a threat
and I feel like this Watchmen series
deals with some heavy issues as well
namely racism but in the same bold
fashion way that the comic book does so
why do you think Watchmen the series is
so effective at tackling these issues
I'll say that something about the sort
of alternate reality that they craft
it's why science fish fit it's why
science fiction works because you've
created this world that is not totally
recognizable there's something off in it
so the stuff that's true or that
reflects our own society really kind of
it really pops um so all the I mean I've
heard people say like it seems strange
that they're they're going with the
Tulsa race riots and all this other
stuff but the other series you know the
comic did tackle Vietnam so you know
they're they're handling real life
issues yeah and I will preface whatever
I'm about to say with I am a chucklehead
so there's not there's not a lot of
weight to what I'm about to say so take
that with a grain of salt however I will
say that I think there's something about
Watchmen being a series where the
characters are looking inward at their
own morality which is it's like this
introspective experience which when it's
against the backdrop of all these like
fears of the time it kind of results in
like people looking and one of
themselves when they're viewing perhaps
I don't know if that makes sense no it
does makes I think people I like I mean
this series opens with a depiction of
the Tulsa race Massacre right that's
very powerful and when it's told through
Watchmen or any sort of superhero story
I think it gets people to pay attention
yeah I think that's powerful I think
that Watchmen has never been afraid to
take a big swing and that might work for
some people it might not work for others
but they are swinging right now and
they're saying we're not afraid to
tackle these massive issues in the same
way that the original graphic novel was
not afraid so it's a different issue now
that we are trying to talk about but
it's the same concept that they're
saying okay we have a stance on this and
we're gonna take that right and I love
the stance that they're taking because
we never saw diverse superheroes in the
Watchmen universe until now now the fact
that Regina King is the face of it you
know I think that's pretty incredible
but I want to ask you guys cuz I know
you're super fans and Watchmen is so
beloved because there could be this
argument here right that this could have
been a standalone series Alan Moore the
creator has been very open he doesn't
like people touching Watchmen he doesn't
like people adapting it he's not in the
credits of the show or the movie do you
agree with more do you feel like
Watchmen should be untouched or do you
like this continued adaptation in my
head his voice kind of sounds like yeah
it's gonna come out no no the next
season song I love him and I love Dave
Gibbons for what they created because it
was something that was really impactful
for me yeah
it is his baby so I get why he wouldn't
want it to be touched when he's not a
part of it I really do get it I'm a
creator and that's really challenging
for somebody that being said if you
can't work on the art I still want the
art to be worked on because I still want
to see more as somebody pun intended I
want to see more just not ours
as somebody who loves Watchmen how does
that grow today in 2019 how do we move
that story forward and just because he
can't work on it doesn't mean there
aren't brilliant minds out there like
Damon Lindelof who can tackle it right
yeah I was gonna say Lindelof of all
people I know like Watchmen even before
the movie came out there were versions
of the script that are horrible they're
not good and they eventually turned it
into a movie a lot of people like you
know some people have issues with it but
having someone like Lindelof who has a
pretty thoughtful creative person like
he's made a lot of shows that really
challenged people and have a lot of new
ideas so it's sort of an ideal situation
as as far as he's also pretty good at
handling universes and yeah building I
think it's also just like a curious
question to think about like is the
creator always the best person to move a
story forward like you were saying like
we saw that with like Lucas and Star
Wars and even like Stephen King having
his issues with the original shining but
it's it is a question I don't know if I
have the answer to it I do think it's I
wish he would be I guess what I will say
to that yeah but I love how I mean I
love what they're doing without him and
I agree with you sometimes creators are
too close to the material and Shane you
brought up the film Watchmen 64% on the
tomato materials yeah 71% audience score
Roxy I know you love it but has over a
million audience reviews so I know a lot
of people feel some type of way about
the film personally I love that they
made it because I don't feel like one
film can encapsulate the magic nosov one
and I think you need a series to do that
I think a series is a better format to
do that as well but I think that the
movie was true to the graphic novel
which is why I liked it and it's
surprising that Alan Moore does not
because it's such a dead ringer I mean
shot-for-shot
at the time yes we do have some changes
like the ending where it's an explosion
as opposed to the squid but there for
the most part is it's an O Maj in the
best kind of way so that's why it works
yeah I love that you brought at the
ending because I wanted to bring that
back to people maybe watching this show
right now can we kind of explain the
squid storm Shane that we were talking
about before because if you watch the
movie didn't read the comic probably
don't know what's going on why why
squids yeah exactly
down yes in the in the comic instead of
setting off some sort of it was like
tied to Manhattan they set off this bomb
in the comic it's it's a they transport
this squid and make it look like an
extraterrestrial from another planet
like we're being invaded yeah it lands
in New York it's incredibly graphic and
bloody yeah which is why there's a lot
of predictions that the squids now
falling from the sky is kind of a never
forget this is what can happen based off
the graphic novel not the movie but is
it a continuation of the hoax or is it
or is this residual from the
transporting of I guess a giant squid
that was created by a biologist Ryan I'm
with you I feel like now the
government's in on it but we'll get to
theories in a second I want to talk to
you guys about the standout performances
because whether you watched whether you
read the novel watched a movie you liked
it or you don't like it
the standout performances are unreal we
have three Oscar winners Regina King
Jeremy Irons Louis Gossett jr. so what
have been your favorite moments or
performances so far I love any time they
cut to vite and Jeremy Irons because I
have no idea what's going on with him
which is similar to the comic where for
the first like two thirds of the comic
you're like well what is this man doing
it's very strange he's like on his own
little great british baking show island
he's like reenacting plays that he wrote
I was like it's basically like just a
continuation of his own ego which is
very telling of his character right he's
incredible but for me it is Regina King
Regina Regina King she is so baller the
way that he grabs the gun like
everything she does she kicks butt in
but she's also this beautiful wonderful
family woman yeah I just think that the
way that they're depicting her is
perfect I agree with you she's a perfect
balance of like strength and warmth and
she makes me like want to be a
not in some way my mom is so proud yes
this week when it was the the Christmas
scene with her yeah she just switches
from it was like just really wonderful
tender scene I was like this is great
which is an audience a house yeah she's
like crawling behind yeah so so good I
really enjoyed Tim Blake Nelson I was
just about this looking-glass I think is
my new favorite watching superhero and
that interrogation scene in the pod was
so sick he's so funny the second
interrogation scene which I guess isn't
one but it is when he's talking to
Regina King in the car when he just
speaks with that almost robotic even
keel voice pretty own he's like that is
that why I'm crying under here or
whatever it's so good but I agree with
you guys Jeremy Irons every time I'm
watching I'm like what the [ __ ] is good
and I have so many theories which is why
I want to get into theories but really
quick we don't know the name of Jeremy
Irons as characters so is he definitely
Ozymandias I said he's Adrian Veidt I
think I think he is we think there was
there was a headline that said Adrian
Veidt is dead on one of the newspapers
right yeah oh he's off minutes so he is
for sure has to be without a doubt the
purple yellow cake I was like okay this
is yeah if he's not him why are they
showing us this man's birthday party
three different times yeah very weird
choices anniversary yeah or how does he
know to put on this play
yeah how does he know what happened I
feel like I would not be utilizing you
guys to the best of my ability discuss
all the Easter eggs we've seen thus far
I will say that one unforgettable
started playing put your fingers
together what are you doing okay we're
gonna do this for each Marty go ahead
and Spielberg it yeah oh yeah every
interview by doing this yeah go do that
kind of stuff anyways when unforgettable
started playing when he was walking
around to get some more wine and I was
like this guy's gonna get sniped in his
own house I'm Judd who I'm talking about
right there was a palpable sense of
dread this entire episode when at
anytime he was alone when I was like
this guy's gonna die and sure enough he
died laughing of help I'm a prophet I'm
not saying I'm not dr. Annette yeah well
why isn't forgettable in Easter egg no
for people Evans Oh in the film in the
film Watchmen unforgettable plays when
the comedian gets murked yeah most
perfect use of the song I'm forgettable
by the way in the opening of the film
the one
alright I loved about the minute one
unforgettable is awesome the graphic
novel now it's please nostalgia perfume
commercials are on oh come on guys you
got it
yeah I feel so cool right now I don't
have that funny perfume
what are some other there are also a ton
of owls like through episode 1 & 2
there's an owl mug there kids dressed as
owls
there's the homage to the ship in the
sky all different owl references based
off of night owl the character from both
the movie and the graphic novel right
and there have been two night owls yea
universe just so everyone knows mhm and
Hollis Mason correct was the first one
and Dan dan dreiberg was the second one
I thought Don Johnson's character Judd
Crawford not Judd Apatow is no I think
he's Dan because he has the under the
hood book on his videos it was written
by the first night out interesting yeah
do we know the whereabouts of Dan
doesn't say on that but he also was in
Archie which is the name of our ship so
I'm like isn't is this dan dreiberg
so theory thanks guys there's there's
been a few also the ending of the pilot
with the blood drip onto the shape I
can't believe that did not occur to me
that they would try to like put that
visual cue in there cuz what had
happened I was like whoa I got a like a
little shiver what had happened why why
why is it so prolific because when I
think when the comedian dies in the
movie end in the comic book he falls out
of the window and there's I don't know
if we can show it but yeah his uh his
pencils off no leave it there Alan
Morris sorry so yeah his he wears that
iconic little smiley face pin it falls
down out of the window after him and a
little drop of blood just specks on it
and it becomes sort of a visual motif
for the whole the whole story and this
was on the police badge was not yeah
that one drop of blood it was a little
different but a similar drop right and I
think the comedian refers to the smiley
face as a badge not a pin oh yeah
apparently pins are like not that bad a
source blood drops in this universe have
a very serendipitous with the way
they've
yeah what about um the noose and yeah
yeah that's interesting I wonder what
their what they're getting at and how
they're gonna use that to tell different
stories throughout the first season of
this or possibly only season I've heard
in the book it was always just sort of a
weird glimpse into like the just the
common folk because they would just cut
to conversations between them and then
we showed the actual comic that he was
via the pirate comics which in this
feels like the American hero story is
like they're embedded story so I hope we
see more I was glad we saw more of it in
episode 2 I wonder if they're gonna
continue that another I don't know if
it's an easter egg or theory but I feel
like there were a lot of twists and
turns in the graphic novel and when we
see that Regina Kings character has been
shot the next thing that we see is her
in the hospital with somebody who
possibly could have shot her if he is a
bad guy Joan Crawford exactly so there
are a lot of moments like that in the
movie and in the novel where the next
image you see is actually the answer to
the question you've been asked oh that's
a really good Easter egg and I think
you're right because when Angela asked
Judd you know did everyone or did you
get shot too I feel like he looks at his
shoulder and he's like everyone got hurt
and he doesn't really answer the
question there and he says everyone else
died except for us so maybe he shot her
and for some reason has a soft spot for
her so yeah we're out of the hospital
well let's get into that what are some
theories and predictions that you guys
have for the show moving forward or
flashbacks or characters that you want
to see I'm super focused on hooded
justice and and who that is and what's
happening in second episode in the
second episode with Muller the the woman
that we see who goes and transcribes in
English that last name is who Hollis is
referencing in the novel could possibly
be hooded justice but maybe a relative
because it's a boy or is it will I mean
I have so many theories about who's
under that hair a lot of people think
it's will Reeves do you guys think so
because he wears a lot of red and the
rope that's used you know hang Jud is
similar to the rope that he had possibly
I know that we see in the in the TV show
that it's a white man
that hood but that could be history just
that's all so it's like the TV show
within the show and maybe an American
here's story and some whitewashing
comedy yeah I thought it was like the
black freighter
you know how the black that's for sure
what they're doing yeah yeah I think it
could be will I'm gonna say it Oh God in
the line there I think could be well
what are some other theories you guys
have or stuff that you'd like to see
happen I'm very curious how they're
gonna work dr. Manhattan into it because
they had that one little clip of him
just being on Mars like tearing his
castle his little palace down I was like
what's he up to
yeah there's no way he's on Mars he's
back right he's there's no way he's on
Mars because we've referenced it 50
times on Mars he's on Mars if he was
actually on Mars why do we keep saying
he's I'm right and you know what else a
reference a lot they say that he doesn't
have the power to shape-shift into
someone else so it makes me think that
maybe Ozymandias or Jeremy Irons his
character like you know all those clones
yes maybe you know dr. Manhattan is his
tinkering I wonder if the castle kind of
looks like his house and him reenacting
the the whole accident that turned him
into dr. Manhattan or the turned you
know I wonder if that's yeah it could be
him can you actually explain that and go
into that for people that haven't read
the novel or movie in what that place
yes so so Vytas ryona if it is vitami
irons character is reenacting the
initial accident that that created dr.
Manhattan when he got caught inside like
a testing chamber and I don't know why
he's so obsessed with it and he's very
method with recreating yes he is he's a
man on fire writing so terrible and he's
like I need real tears I love one via
the other clone is he's like you'll be
him now and the guy was like yeah like I
know you're gonna burn up tomorrow know
why that was so wild to watch because as
I'm watching I'm thinking there is no
way he's actually burning a person these
are great special effects or he's got
these robot he went there didn't you
earning endure and the guy was Kentucky
Fried yeah it was definitely burnt to a
crisp straight up so they're reenacting
that showing how he got to be which is
kind of great for people who didn't read
the novel or who had never seen the
movie because now they know what the
origins
right also low stakes by the way I do
love the moment of him me and Shane
talked about this before that that that
shot of dr. Manhattan just destroying
his castle like a kid playing with
tinker toys yeah it just it just cuts to
this very ambient shot there's no noise
it's just him like the knocking stuff
down on Mars yeah yeah bored up there
and for everyone watching just you know
we've only seen 2 episode so far and
another big thing that we learned in the
episode last night was that will is
Angela's grandfather so where do we
think that story lines in yeah I think
it's difficult because right now she
people don't even know that she's a
police officer and then they don't know
she has this other secret identity as
well and now it's her family so she's
already protecting him before she knows
that it's her grandfather now that she
knows that she's not gonna turn him in
and we don't even know if he is the one
who hung the chief of police even though
he asks her do you think I could lift
200 pounds right so I think that she's
they're gonna team up in some way
it was pretty obvious though the hiding
spot that that they found the cloak yes
I wondered that yeah when they found
Donald took over James cloak yeah Jed
Crawford I keep wanting to call him shut
out the talent in my head
I don't know many Judds I think that
that is not his right is there no I do
not think that I think it's his father's
oh I hoping that oh I think a lot of
this show is about paying for the sins
of your family members and older
generations and I think that it's there
possibly as a reminder to him as what
his family has done and how he has to
fight against this because it would just
be too too obvious and too early of a
reveal to have him be that bad of a
person and there's so many other
questions that would come up if that
really if he's really a member of the
KKK if he really is this white
supremacist then why does he live his
life like this well the thing is he has
that painting which is the title of
episode 2 right Marshall feeds of the
Comanche horsemanship yeah I'm curious
to know how is this white knight
reference going to be tied together
Jeremy Irons his character rides a white
horse there's a white horse in the
painting the white knight is an
another name for the Tulsa massacre how
is this all going to play together
speaking of which I'm kind of curious
how Rorschach became the figurehead for
white supremacy and then the show it
feels accurate I kind of get it yeah I
wonder if we're going to see any other
why is that accurate to people who
haven't watched cuz it was ultra violent
in a way or I guess in the comics I
think just because he was an extremist
and it seems like something that someone
would latch on to like they're certainly
misinterpreting a lot of his like ideas
and but he did send his his diary to the
newspaper at the end of the comic right
if Rorschach was alive today I don't
think he would be a member of this group
I don't think based off of what he stood
for people could read what he was saying
and interpreted this way it was like a
Rorschach blot yeah and if you guys
actually go on that peedee peedee peedee
a that I was telling you about I think
they explain what happened in those
thirty so years no no the masks
yeah vault if you you don't need to read
it but I hope that they explain this
yeah it's like a PDF I hope they explain
this in the show but I'm curious to know
when you guys read Watchmen graphic
novel I feel like everyone kind of sat
around their couch and they were like
who do you relate to more and for a lot
of people it was Rorschach right like I
read it when I was in college and I was
like yeah he's cool but in retrospect as
I've grown up like heck I had some issue
so how do you feel about you know his
iconic mask now being the face of the
7th Calvary when I read this there was
nobody that I was like I want to grow up
to you got some issues did you close I
mean that would be kind of cool but so
emotionless you can't you don't want to
be sleeping with somebody while you're
working on your work outside yeah that's
a good memory in the comic he's like in
1959 I was doing this and he's like on
November 8th I'm like that would be a
really great school well there were
aspects of each of the characters that
you kind of wanted right but except for
some of them like the comedian I would
say outright probably none of it I've
done any pod guy weird humor
yeah but I like the references to
Rorschach and people who are looking at
the out of the Minutemen or the Watchmen
and pulling different traits from them
and that's the start for this series
what are some other shows on TV that you
think people should check out if they're
into watchmen so shows like Watchmen I
think if you're into Watchmen a show
that I love that people have not been
really talking about is Doom Patrol now
it's a DC property so if you like
Watchmen it's a comic-book property by
DC and it's weird so that in that aspect
it's kind of similar because it's very
off beat like squid falling from the sky
that kind of stuff happens on the show
all of the time and it's also got that
hero aspect where the heroes are not the
best people on the planet they
definitely have more layers to their
onions and like I said it's off it's
strange it's on DC Universe and if you
want to be part of something that seems
really weird but also kick but then doom
patrols we're at that I'm sold Shane
what about you I'd go with leftovers
which is Damon Lindelof show before I
was also HBO Roxy you were saying you
were a fan massive massive I'm credible
I think it's very handy for for people
watching Watchmen because you sort of
get a feel for how he approaches stories
because he always like comes at stuff
from a weird angle flashbacks as well so
many flashbacks he sort of took
everything he learned from lost I know a
lot of people have some beefs with that
show I love it and and improved upon
them and so when I heard he was doing
Watchmen I was like yeah perfect and I
think I've heard to the rumor mill that
like leftovers you know how certain
episodes focus on one character I heard
that that's what's coming up or what we
should word you for watching man yeah
what about you right I would say I guess
not in the sense of tone because the
show I'm about to suggest is not as
strange or weird as Watchmen is but in
terms of dystopian future I would say
man in the high castle that's basically
the entire premise of that show is this
alternate set of futures and if you're
into that sort of thing it's a fun show
yeah I would say check out the boys cuz
I love seeing superheroes in this raw
real human way which is why I love
Watchmen and I think the boys does that
and sees
- comes out summer 2020 so you have time
to catch up on it so as major fans we
could obviously go on about Watchmen all
day every day are you guys gonna stick
with it do you like where the story's
going so far yeah I'm gonna yeah I'll
watch it until as long as it's done I'm
gonna watch it
I love Damon Lindelof I love watch I'm
here I'll be here to talk about it
whenever you want yeah I think I'll
stick with it I have a TV yeah I have a
TV I'll watch it 100% I'm a watch woman
now I this is definitely gonna be a show
that I stay with no matter what even if
there are highs and lows because I feel
like they know what they're doing they
have an end game and I've got to get
there yeah I'm so excited to see what
happens because I heard that the series
gets so so good but now it is time for
our fresh picks these are shows doesn't
have to do with Watchmen just any show
on TV that you think people should add
to their watch list what are you guys
watching on becoming a god in Central
Florida if you've never heard of that
and then you're not alone because nobody
knows what that show is on Showtime yes
yes it's on Showtime it's Kirsten Dunst
it is weird it is a pyramid scheme show
and you're watching it all happens
screaming at the television like don't
do it every single episode I can't
believe this isn't getting more buzz
right now because it's awesome it's
really great do you think it's because
it's on Showtime maybe it's like hard
for people to find I don't know I just
think that it's there's so much content
now there's so many TV shows that I
think that this might be like succession
in season two more people are gonna
catch on to it if we get there hopefully
enough people watch that we do but if
you are interested in it you'll know off
the first episode if you like it the way
the first episode ends you're either in
or you're out
I think the first episodes for free on
YouTube - youtube king himself ytk shane
what's your first pick I would go with
it just ended righteous gemstones I
haven't heard a lot of people talking
about it I'm not always sold on on Danny
McBride stuff so I approached it with
caution it's got the usual like
incredibly vulgar vibe to it but and
he ended up surprising me I wasn't
totally sold from episode 1 but by the
end of the season it lands in a place
that's surprisingly heartwarming it's
weird it's the most vulgar insane
heartwarming show I've ever watched it
is very funny ok
also there's a woman on it named Edie
Patterson who I haven't seen in anything
else I think she wrote for SNL and was
on Vice Principals but she is so funny
told me that's what I'm here to do there
was a part of me that wants to say great
British baking show just because just
because of Jeremy Irons is birthday cake
Island but I will say I will say I'm
just gonna say the good place I don't
know I know everyone knows the good
place is great it's the last season you
could watch it live not a lot of great
shows are actually live on television
where you can watch and it becomes an
event get it while it's hot yeah that's
true I like that I'm watching living
with yourself
ok seen that yet one already like Paul
Rudd playing Paul Rudd and opposite Paul
Rudd yeah I saw that on a bus stop yeah
it's really good it's very easy to watch
the episodes are like 25 minutes long
there's only eight episodes there's a
great cliffhanger at the end for season
two and Paul woods just so likeable and
funny and there's a Tom Brady cameo
that's a little controversial right now
but I that Saul I can say but it's
definitely a reason to tune in you know
what I'm so I've got my finger on the
pulse of sports so well that when I
watch that first episode he showed up I
was like who's this guy
and then in the next episode they urge
they have a mentioned it was Tom Brady I
was like no idea sitting next to a
Bostonian right now my heart hurts is
the twist there's a third Paul Rudd well
you'll have to you'll have to watch the
noise spoilers show Ryan so I dribble it
slows that information but yeah a great
bull ride Wow just wait yeah that's a
lot of it I don't think I can so much
alright guys well that is our show I
couldn't have done it without our
unmasked vigilantes Roxie Shae
and Ryan thank you guys so much for
joining me on the couch today and for
more on watchmen head on over to Rotten
Tomatoes comm also please comment below
and let us know what you think about the
series so far we love reading your
theories also don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and notification Bell
so you don't miss any future episodes
join us next time as we talk all about
the mandalorian on disney plus so soaked
i'm nazzer Prez and i'll see you guys
next time
[Music]